good morning and good or good afternoon
everybody um i'm rami karam aziz uh i'm
currently the head of microbiology and
immunology research program
at the children's cancer hospital of
cairo egypt i'm also a
professor in cairo university
uh
so
today i'm really excited to share with
you a
presentation
about pharmaco microbiomics
i will hope within the the next 30
minutes i will be able to define and to
suggest how we can translate that into
uh
to the clinic into clinical applications
and pharmaceutical uh applications as
well so basically uh
my thighs is translating
pharmacomicrobiomics from a microbiome
cloud of uncertainty to
pharmaceutical and medical applications
all right so i like to start i i know uh
this is uh semi interactive
you you you can hear me but i cannot
hear you at the time being or not at the
same moment at least but i i'm assuming
that you can
raise hands or answer this quiz
uh
if you were in a in a lecture hall i
would ask you like this picture which
hopefully you can see
uh basically how does it relate to the
session uh type of the microbiome and
precision medicine so my question is how
do you think this relates
to precision medicine how does it relate
to the human microbiome
you may have very good idea about what
precision medicine and human microbiome
are
or you may wait until we discuss their
definitions but
really just take a moment maybe not on a
small piece of paper or just take a
mental note of how is this related like
this looks like
some targets somebody's shooting at them
or or throwing darts
so how is this related to the human
microbiome and precisionled
the first third of my talk will be to
talk about the human microbiome and the
human microbiome project or hmt and how
it all started and how we got into this
field of pharmacomicrobiomics
so basically uh
microbiome is obviously microscopic
microbiology
and microbiology itself is a quite
recent field this is a picture of anthem
that live in
who was
maybe 300 350 years ago
first time uh with a small microscope he
invented it it gave him new eyes however
the invention remained buried maybe for
another
couple of hundred years so what the
entire microbiology field is less than
170 years old
and it was all giving us new eyes
because of the microscope later like in
the mid
middle of the 20th century we discovered
dna and dna sequencing laser and started
having again new eyes
to be able to see what we cannot see
with with a microscope even using dna
sequence and dna fingerprinting
and obviously to to everybody the the
human genome
uh sequence came out
well
it has been fully achieved maybe this
year with all the details but
since the start of the the new century
the 21st century the human genome was
out there was announced in 2001 as a
draft both in science and nature and it
it caused the revolution since then
however the the human genome was
supposed to tell us why we are different
as you can see on the science covered by
people from different colors different
ages different traces
different
however the differences could not all be
explained in our genes there are other
differences in how we look and how we
respond to disease and how they respond
to therapy as well
so later there were so many uh
regulatory facts like we look at gene
regulation for example but again there's
still a missing part and that was one of
the missing parts was the human
microbiome the human microbiome was
popularized very well in the
early
first decade of the century like 2005
2006 we started hearing
about the human microbiome
and it took a few years to make it to
the press so this this cover is actually
from the economist except
the root on it 10 to the power of 13 is
the number of our human cells 10 to the
power of 14 is the scale of number of
nucleated microbial cells
and
so our nucleated cells are one order of
magnitude less than the microbial cells
living within us and you can see this
title in the economist microbes makes
them so are we
fully human
when we are carrying more microbial
cells from different
origins different microbes different
genomes
it was the question of the decade at
that time
so uh again let me start
uh by defining the term so that
uh we're all on the same line whether
you're new or you're you're an expert of
the micro the term microbiome was was
suggested by joshua lederberg in in the
year 2000 describing the the sum of
microbial genomes living in our body and
it was suggested as an extension of the
human genome however microbiome can also
be seen in two ways
so the first one is a summation of
microbial genomes or it could be also
seen as the microbial metagenome which
is all the microbes in a certain
environment which is
the different environment in our body or
it can be seen as the micro of the biome
the microscopic part of the biome or the
living system
and most of these have been suggested by
us and others one of the articles you
can go to is uh in gut pathogens and the
link is provided here
so it's really important to define the
terms and this is uh what joshua
lederberg used in the year 2000
uh before that you cannot really find
the word microbiome on
the word microbiota was used a lot to
describe the sum of bacteria living in
human bodies but the word microbiome was
maybe mentioned only once or twice in
in very sporadic terms before the year
2000
the other thing which i really really
think
would be interesting
is what is the microbiome
really looks like
and here i want to show you a few
pictures
you can
you can pick which one of them describes
the microbiome best so there is the
the picture that is mostly common now is
the microbiome as an extra organ or a
forgotten organ it's a second brain or
its second liver
however
maybe this picture of the microbiome as
a different organ is quite fragmented
because an organ is after all
from the word organ it's organized it's
inherited it's stable more or less you
know except for our immune cells most of
our organs are quite genetically stable
as well
uh
the alternative model that i i would
like to suggest
would be a microbiome cloud model and
this is inspired by the uncertainty in
the atomic structure
uh the uncertainty principle and how the
electrons can be in a cloud so
i'm trying to visualize that this was
inspired by an article in the scientific
american actually so this illustration
is like a human with a microbiome
density around it so in the gut and the
oral cavity we have the highest density
of microbes but also on our skin and
elsewhere but if you come 10 minutes
after the microbes have already changed
a few days after they have changed
there are hormonal factors
there are geographical factors there are
diet factors there are internal
individual factors so there is so many
factors that make uh the microbes
different around our body so what what
you what microbes you had yesterday are
different from what you had today and
significantly different if you you got
a diarrhea for example so this is really
important to consider so these microbes
are not there's so many they have
genomes but they are not as genetically
stable as we imagine so this is the
message of the first part of my talk
basically we are inhabited
by a
huge cloud of genomes and and this cloud
is you know not just figuratively but
actually literally we have a cloud of
bacteria surrounding our skin but also
again in all our cavities basically
and they contribute a lot of genes and
these genes at some point will be
expressed and they will perform
functions so they definitely enrich our
gene pool but they initiate in a way
that is uncertain and this is the first
part of my talk and the first part of
the title there is an uncertainty of the
microbiome
and now i go back to the slide i started
with you know
so how is this related to the human
microbiome or
basically i just defined the human
microbiome as a cloud so let's say
you want to reach
you just want
you got some food in your body
this food gets metabolized by our
enzymes but there is also a cloud
surrounding our enzyme which is the
microbial enzyme that differs again
on different days of the year it differs
according to our diet even our mood
sometimes
so how is this related again
to to precision medicine and how how can
we explain these clouds first and decode
it
so the the second part of my talk is
about the decoding of the human
microbiome which is is more or less
about the bioinformatics behind it and
the coding is a very very old activity
it dates i mean to archaeology and when
people
find manuscripts or old papyruses and
they start trying to make a story and
often the the long stories that we
studied in the history books they
actually come from fragmented very
fragmented pieces of manuscripts but we
can tell like the king went to certain
war and then you can guess from the rest
of this even if some words are missing
you can make the entire story based on
other manuscripts and other events and
this is what basically everybody who
works on genomics and metagenomics does
we get a lot of dna
uh letters
you know the dna alphabet the ac gt and
we try to make sense out of them to try
to build a single story so
my first experience and here i'm going
to mix some of my experiences as well
with the concepts because i don't want
this to be just a
theoretical theoretical lecture but also
so so one of the works i have been
earlier involved in since 2005 and 2006
was
trying to make sense out of microbial
genomes and at the time there were not
that many they were less than 500
microbial genomes in the databases today
they are i don't know i i don't want to
say millions but there's so many
microbial genomes
uh
and there had there was a need to human
expertise but also to my computational
tools because
no human can take one genome and
annotate 5 000 genes for example that's
typically the e coli you know one of the
commonest bacteria
the mycobacterium tuberculosis have even
more genomes and i i can name a lot of
bacteria that have
more genes in them
than any human can handle just mentally
or or can claim knowledge of so instead
we we always needed computer
systems however again a computer system
alone can be disastrous so because it
cannot do all the predictions without
very clean databases of human knowledge
so one of the earliest attempts and it's
one of the
most successful until now
tools is the rast server which stands
for rapid annotation using subsystems
technology
and it was used to interpret individual
genomes but later there was mgras there
were other derivatives
to interpret genomes in a microbial
community
but again why is the computer not enough
there is a risk
there is a big risk
for example if you just take
a very classical biology example you go
to a forest and try to name some of the
creatures there some of the organisms
and you find all these four pieces and
now we try to assemble them without any
human knowledge in fact if a computer
tries to assemble these four parts
it may fall in a
very common so-called timer
and and
and this climber could be very
attractive but it doesn't exist so when
when we are interpreting stories and
building models we have to make sure
uh they actually represent
reality and truth and one of the
applications of the success model used
of using computer assembly with human
knowledge was the discovery of
a microbiome related virus which is a
microbial virus that we named craft
phase and this was discovered in 2000.
and published in 2014 in nature
communications and it made a lot of news
because this virus is a microbial virus
it doesn't infect human it infects the
microbes
in our intestine
and it was surprising that like all our
history we could not find this virus and
it turns out to be a a big family of
viruses called the class like
viruses
and many of them live in the guts of
humans others live in the gut of of
primates
and it was not discovered until that
time why because most of the genes did
not look like any other genes and it
needed smart microbial assembly
which was only available with the
technology of the time and of course
human knowledge of the system
so now we know that this class phage is
very highly spread
in different continents with different
variants
i don't want to go through so much
technical details but when you are
trying to interpret microbial genomes uh
you fall into some
easy parts and some less easier
some challenging parts so parts of the
genomes that are easier to interpret are
those that encode the environment
performs the metabolic functions
everything that we studied in
biochemistry basically is relatively
easier to interpret because the enzymes
are conserved and the genes are
are well defined by all the biochemists
throughout the ages
however the the more challenging parts
are the so-called mobile elements the
jumping genes plasmid transposons
they are very important to interpret so
we work with rob edwards and maya
brybert with pictures you can see in
this slide
on defining transposable elements and
bacteriophages also which are again
bacterial viruses because they are
the variable variable element in
microbial genomes and
some of the plasmid and
these transposable elements they carry
resistance genes so again it was it's
very important and this is again a part
of
what i'm interested in and what i worked
on a few years ago in collaboration with
dr raniacyan and ali
was
pictured in this slide
we improved the
resistance
prediction in microbial genomes and we
call this resistor estimation
now the one last issue about the
interpretation and then i will move to
the third and last part of my talk so
again the first part of my talk was
about the concept of the microwave
the second part of how to technically
interpret it and how not to fall into
traps or make mistakes by assembling the
wrong pictures you know the wrong data
from from the information we have
so now there is a big debate and it's
it's not like uh a philosophical one but
it's more like a microbiological
are we more interested in who they are
or what they do and here i'm talking of
course they about microbes that inhabit
us
so some scientists would spend a lot of
time on
taxonomy and dividing and
classifying all the microbes in our body
while others are more interested in the
functional part and it's really
important to understand
uh why each is important i mean
so
like you can say
it's not what you do but who you are
in social life that may be interesting
but for bacteria
it's really uh since we are you know we
are humans and we are interested in what
bacteria this was this slide is
it's quite complicated i don't want to
go through it in videos but i want you
to check the upper part and the lower
part uh you can see the lower parts are
very uh you know the patterns are very
similar right there is red blue and
they're more or less similar these are
the microbial
functions performed by the bacteria in
several twins and their mothers
so
the twins are similar to one another but
also similar to
other twins
on how their bacteria function but if
you go to the identity of these bacteria
or the identity of viruses there you
will find a lot of discrepancy and what
is the message here is you may have a
lot of players that are different but
they perform the same function it's more
like a team
a sports team so
you have defenders and you have uh you
know
midfield like whatever the sport is i
don't want to be biased to football or
soccer but basically it doesn't matter
who is the player name is but this guy
is going to score this guy is going to
defend and this guy is going to be a
playmaker and so on it doesn't matter if
it's streptococcus or staphylococcus
i mean it matters definitely for
taxonomists but for for the sake of the
human uh
metabolism and human health
whatever whoever is there what matters
more is what functions they do and
surprisingly this inspiration was there
a hundred years ago a hundred years ago
the microbiology was all based on
microscopy and culture there was no dna
analysis
and this is a paper
now 110 years ago basically from 2000
and uh from 1909 and i discovered it in
2009 and published a short commentary on
it i was very happy to find this paper
because it says that a considerable
portion
of fecal math is made up of the bodies
of bacteria whether they are dead or
alive so all our this this inspiration
like this insight was there since 1909
that most of our
our body uh
our fecal material in the abdomen is
made up of bacteria and it's like a huge
incubator inside us and what is really
inspiring here and insightful is it's
what bacteria do rather than what they
are that commands attention since our
interest center on the host here which
is the human rather than the parasite so
this was
seen by
fubal smith very insightful and
published in jbc who are thankfully
keeping the records for 100 years
and open access as well so this is
really interesting so again message
number one we have a microbiome cloud of
uncertainty surrounding us
now decoding this cloud is even more
challenging so you already have a cloud
there is uncertainty but even decoding
it is challenging however what is a
little bit comforting
is that you don't really have to know
every member of the microbiota to be
able to understand what they do if we
can just assess their functions by
finding the gene sequences
and analyzing them we can try to predict
the functions and biochemical pathways
they perform
now i want i want to move on how is this
related to our health and then then to
get
straight to the medical and
pharmaceutical applications so the human
microbiome
has been
now popularized for 20 years maybe
almost 15 or yeah 15 years of
stress about the human microbiome most
people know that microbiology can
control a lot of our functions
not only the diet and assimilation but
sometimes our mood sometimes our
response to to different stimuli
and this is all based on a dysbiosis and
ubiosis paradigm so basically very
simply it's more about war and peace or
more about you know there is balance and
peace on the upper picture here in the
intestine bacteria are the right
proportions
there is not there is not a single like
ideal microbiome for every human but
more or less whatever keeps the bacteria
in piece together uh
the metabolic
synergy or symbiosis with the host
however when
when our diet changes when some in fact
other factors change or
we are stressed when the bacteria are
stressed
when we eat uh a lot of junk food
this balance will change and sometimes
it's fatal like sometimes it changes
through uh
at this biotic state so it's like utopia
and dystopia so it's a dysbiotic state
in which um
there is a favor of causing disease so
there is a stage before disease called
dysbiosis where you are imbalanced and
in this stage luckily irreversible so
here's the disease is colorectal cancer
and it could be
uh really quite obvious that colorectal
cancer
has a microbial factor and it's
especially by bacteria called fuso
bacteria for example and some types of e
coli
all right so so i want to to mention a
couple of of examples from my research
mariam is one of my students for example
and she looked at dysbiosis in the eye
and she found again
to make a long story short that
dysbiosis
in uh
these called concentric devices is very
significant so you don't have to have
bacteria coming from the outside causing
conjunctivity even if there is a minor
injury to one of the two eyes
that i will start getting this biosis
the balance will will be uh
broken in the eye and then some bacteria
will prevail that will cause the
conjunctivitis while the other eye is
still not infected so by comparing the
two eyes she managed to look at that
another student of mine looked at the
disease since
i am in
egypt and egypt is one of the countries
that is most affected by hepatitis c
and currently there is a huge effort to
eliminate the disease but
we are still
having hepatitis c as an endemic disease
so
abdulrahman performed a quite uh
preliminary and pilot study but luckily
was confirmed by so many studies after
that and he found that there is
just look at these uh
blue and red dots the red dots represent
people who are infected the blue dots
represent people who are healthy and
almost all the red dots except one
there's always exceptions in biology
are separated from the blue ones which
means their microbiome composition is
different
so my
my third message here
uh is that microbes play major functions
that affect our health and
definitely if
any food we ate any natural products any
prebiotics will affect our health so now
how about drug designing if we are
talking about
health
then drugs come immediately if the
microbes have this strong metabolic
capacity they can break down products
and they can
even deal with toxins and if we have
this cloud of microbes inside us and
around our skin how can we relate with
drugs
and it it's really important uh to know
that drugs and microbes are very in a
very old relation even before the
discovery of bacteria and microbes we
have been eating microbes as drugs like
just think of all the yogurts with
probiotics that we eat
and we have been producing a lot of
drugs the most of course popular of them
is antibiotics that come from bacteria
and fungi
so microbes and drugs are very well
connected actually
bugs and drugs
but now we are facing like here is a
small like a small conceptual or
philosophical thing so you're targeting
precision medicine and precision
medicine
means you want to treat every patient in
the most optimal way like treat or
prevent a disease uh taking into account
genes and environment and lifestyle and
now you cannot ignore one major uh
factor which is a microbiome so going
back to my very very
first slide or like the quilt i gave you
you want to target you know you have a
target you want to shoot there
you want to hit the
the eye however you are blind basically
we are blind because we cannot see these
microbes we cannot read them we need dna
sequencing to read them but also because
they are changing so you are shooting in
a fog you know you are targeting and
this is why the first slide relates for
how it relates to precision medicine
you're trying to shoot here and hit the
highest precision while it's foggy and
even the fog thickness changes
so uh again back to the
microbiome cloud model and i hope i'm
not here
getting into so much concept but very
very simple like just think of the sun
and the clouds right when the weather is
cloudy it's masking most of the sun
being
different different organisms react
differently so mosquitoes for example
they don't like the light very much but
some flowers like the light very much so
if your cloud
is thin so here if the microbiome cloud
is thin
a certain drug we're just here talking
about drugs can have different effects
on different arguments
and the same drug is used but with a
different microbiome composition
different microbiome cloud these
creatures here or this i mean targets
here will act differently so when there
is more sun that sunflower is happy the
mosquito is not when there is less
sunlight the mosquito is happiness and
just a simplistic example
now if you change your drug another
complexity so let's say you change from
drug a to drug b because it's causing
you side effects
again or drug b may be like the moon so
it will have different effects on
different targets but it's also not just
the drug and the target but there is a
third factor here which is the
microbiome cloud and why it's a cloud
because it changes all the time
it could be there it could be absent it
could be sick it could be sin and so on
so this uh
this kind of brings my talks about to
the you know
the topic the main you know epic point
here is that we are looking at human
response to drugs
and initially we know that the human
genes can so this slide shows
if you're seeing it here like look at
the different arrows every gene or
transcription factors in our body could
be different from one person to another
and that's why there was a so-called
pharmacogenetics
and with the human genome achievement we
know that pharmacogenomics is the
science that studies or the field of
studies how the entire composition of
our genome may make me respond to drugs
and in a very good way another person
responds to them
very slowly and the third person
actually gets food gets gets
intoxication or gets a
huge side effects now add an additional
layer of microbes like this big cloud
surrounding ours you know so now uh this
is how we started uh the term pharmaco
microbiomics
and this started with a key paper that
was in a small journal
in 2010 by scala and colleagues and
we suggested the term pharmaco
microbiomics as uh
you know how the drug
the different pharmaco
the word pharmaco is latin for drugs how
they are affected by the microbiome and
how they affect the microbiome as well
so very quick definition of terms so for
macro microbiomics we mean by it's how
our human microbiome and its variation
so how two different people with two
different microbiomes will
respond differently to drugs and how two
drugs can modulate our microbiome
it's very related to pharmacogenomics
and pharmacogenetics
a term a close by term is toxic
microbiomex is again how our microbiome
can affect how we respond to different
toxins in the environment or pollutants
we call them xenobiotics
there are other derivatives for
macrometagenomics for macro metabolomics
for malacca
with an m and i don't want to go too
much into details especially that my
time is coming up but you can read about
this in experts opinion drug metabolism
in 2018
in a paper
uh entitled drug pharmacobiomics and
toxic microbiomes but basically
we are humans we have our genes we have
the microbial genes and this affects
uh
the drugs we take so how we can analyze
this we can just ask who is there what
are the bacteria there we can ask what
they are doing or what they are able to
do through metagenomics
or meta transcriptomics by looking at
the rna of these bacteria or
metaproteomics by looking at the
proteins from these bacteria or by
looking at metabolomics and all of these
are omic sciences you can just look at
all the metabolites
in urine for example and you will be
surprised that maybe one third of them
sometimes doesn't come from our human
enzymes they come from the effects of
microbial enzymes on drugs
same about blood like a lot of
metabolites in our blood come from
microbial products so let's just you can
guess that
the gut microbes and can affect our
liver enzymes it can affect the drug
directly and there are so many examples
of this i want to name a few because of
the time i just i will just name them
just acetaminophen which is panadol or
paracetamol or
tylenol in different countries
it is affected
by microbes digoxin which is an
important glycosides for like it treats
heart diseases heart failure
it could be degraded by the bacteria so
some patients could never respond to it
and it's very risky and some anti-cancer
drugs and even an anti-hiv drug
tenofovir was found to be less
efficient in african women because they
carried different bacteria called
gardenerella
so my students and i built a database
since we got into this actually it's
approaching its 10th anniversary it was
released on 11 11 2011. we just picked
the date because it was exciting to the
students especially
uh the the website is free to access
anybody can go to it's called
farmacomicrobiomex
you can just click for mac
microbiomics.com and you get there you
can search it has over 100 relations now
between different drugs you can just
search for a drug by name or you can
just browse through the chemicals or
publications
and find all the relations just one
example here if you look at the jocks
and there are three papers supporting
the relation between bacteria and
digoxin
and you can read details and you can go
to the paper if you because maybe you
know you won't be convinced by the
relation here so you can go to the
original paper describing this
right i'm getting close to ending my
talk here so again what was that saying
alright so we have a cloud of
uncertainty because we have a lot of
microbes who interfere with our
metabolism whether we want it or not
they they're actually favorable
to our health
it cannot be healthy without some of
your microbes but also sometimes they
cause
unfortunate events
and and they also now affect i mean we
have known for a long time that microbes
can degrade drugs but now it's it's a
focus of research and it's very
important in developing developing new
drugs
and i just want to add one concept is
that it's not just uh
we're not talking just about drugs that
we are taking like sometimes vices or
over the counter and even food so for
example this is a research i'm involved
in with a colleague dr mohammad farag
he's actually helping us look at the
effect of polyphenols which you can find
in green tea and then pomegranate and
like all these nice
nice healthy foods and how they can
reverse the carcinogenic effect
of polyaromatic which you can see on the
left like when you eat
grilled meat and there is a lot of
charring there it tastes yummy but it's
it's carcinogenic actually so
we are studying how these polyphenols
can reverse the effects and my grad
name is hebba she's looking at there is
a big difference here just to check
any detail these two two slides
two different graphs there are two
different classes of bacteria that one
of them goes up and the other goes down
when when we feed the rest with
pomegranates for a long while
so it's really interesting uh now i i
just want to conclude my talking what is
coming next
it's really hard to predict the future
but
a few years ago we tried to have like
crystal ball
in 2010 actually we tried to predict
what medicine will look like when what
personalized or precision medicine will
look like
uh with knowledge of the microbiome and
we it was in the paper uh by this color
itself if you want to look it up
the preprint is available for free and
we just predicted three things which i
think they're almost coming through now
personalized probiotic cocktails so if
you're in a cancer hospital for example
and your patients are responding really
poorly i mean they're responding well to
chemotherapy but they're also having a
lot of side effects adverse effects
you can have a and this is happening
personalized nutrition you can just give
each of the give each of them a mixture
of probiotics and different types of
food that will be ideal to restore their
natural microbiota so that they
handle these drugs better with less side
effects personalized fish cocktails is
already happening you can make phage
bacteriophage cocktail which are
bacterial viruses
like let's say
a clostridium a type of clostridium
bacteria or e coli is specifically known
to be hepatotoxic or carcinogenic and
it's there in our intestine we detected
it you can use it's a very it's like
smart for you know there is no smart war
but there is smarter world instead of
just throwing the bomb on a village you
just can't target
uh a specific place like a weapon an
armed uh
you know storage unit or something with
a very smart
targeted weapon so this is what we do
like bacteria not
like what scientists do in that field
bacteriophages specific viruses they
just go and kill
eliminate the specific type of bacteria
that may cause cancer and maybe very
soon you will go to the doctor and do
some resist tomography like just look at
your intestine and see
how many resistant bacteria to different
antibiotics that are even harmless
bacteria but this will alert you that
when you take the next antibiotic
you may not respond to it because the
harmless bacteria will be able to
degrade it so all this
could have been science fiction in 2010
but it's getting very close to reality
now
i took about five minutes more so i
apologize for this but i i really was
one and still am excited to share with
you pharmaco microbiomics is a new field
relatively but it describes a very well
known phenomenon that microbes are very
capable of metabolism they degrade drugs
they degrade
polygons they integrate pollutants and
our cells are surrounded by a lot of
these microbes they are like a cloud
they are full of rabbit uncertainty
however when we work hard on decoding
them using a combination of human and
computer
tools human knowledge and computer tool
we get a lot of reward we learn a lot
and we save hopefully save and really
save a lot of lives or ease
the life of so many especially because i
work in a cancer hospital like if we can
just make the children's life better by
giving them better nutrition that
restores their microbiome so
we are at the stage of really
translating pharmacomicrobiomics into
better pharmaceutical and clinical
applications
uh and i hope many of you will be
interested in this field and we learn
how to do it so that it becomes routine
in the clinic
like so many pharmacogenetics are now
routine so at some point
maybe a stool sample from a patient can
uh improve their health and therapy i
thank you so much for your attention and
i welcome any questions if you send it
to me through the email provided
i'd like just to acknowledge case by
pictures and names of all these students
and postdoctoral
trainees who helped me with all the work
that i mentioned and i'd like to thank
the organizers uh one more time for
inviting me to this great event thank
you